global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with a question many of us are
wondering about once we get vaccinated
for covid19
what will we be allowed to do only a
tiny fraction of canadians have had the
shot at this point
as of today only about 567 000 canadians
are fully vaccinated
in the us by comparison about 30 million
people are fully vaccinated
and today the american centers for
disease control set out the first public
health guidelines for those
who are fully vaccinated these are us
guidelines not canadian
but they do offer a glimpse into what
life might be like for all of us
in the months ahead jackson proskow has
tonight's top story
okay you ready each shot provides a dose
of hope that life might soon return to
normal
relax in guidelines for the newly
vaccinated the u.s centers for disease
control suggests that may in fact be
possible
slowly the recommendations issued today
are just a first step
the cdc advises people who have been
vaccinated can
gather in small groups indoors without
masks
beginning two weeks after their final
dose the science of coven 19 is complex
and our understanding of the virus
continues to rapidly evolve
the big unknown is if the virus can
still be spread by people who've been
vaccinated
the advice airs on the side of caution
vaccinated people can visit with the
unvaccinated in small groups without
masks or distancing
so long as those unvaccinated
individuals are not considered high risk
over 65 or with a pre-existing condition
in public vaccinated people should
continue to wear masks
practice distancing and avoid travel for
now
it is the most tempting thing if you're
fully vaccinated to
just want everything to go back to
normal i think the most
important thing to remember is the
majority of people around you
are not vaccinated right now in short
the advice brings back some normalcy
vaccinated grandparents could visit
unvaccinated low-risk family members who
live nearby
in that situation hugs are considered
okay too
these guidelines are just for the u.s
where nearly 10 percent of the
population is now fully vaccinated
health canada isn't relaxing any
measures for anyone yet
and says until a larger number of people
across canada are vaccinated
use of multiple personal preventive
practices at once
will still be needed the cdc admits its
advice is likely to change over time as
the science and the virus both evolve
and despite the rush to get back to
normal the number of daily deaths and
cases in the u.s remains alarmingly high
and those virus variants are likely to
put these vaccination guidelines
to the test donna all right jackson
prosco in washington thanks
in canada the number of people getting
very sick and dying from kobit 19 has
fallen sharply from when it was at its
peak but
canadians are still dying every day it
was
one year ago today that the first person
in canada is known to have died from
covet 19
he was a man in its 80s at a long-term
care home in north vancouver
since then more than 22 thousand
canadians have died
the prime minister has designated this
thursday a national day of observance
to honor all the canadians who died in
the pandemic
there is new data today that reveals how
vaccines have already saved hundreds of
lives in this country
researchers in ontario say making
long-term care homes the first
priority in its vaccine rollout has
prevented more than 2 600
infections 257 hospitalizations and
616 deaths eight weeks after
vaccinations began
there was an 89 reduction in cases in
long-term care residents
and a 79 percent reduction in health
care workers
as vaccines start rolling out to the
general population there are still
concerns highly
contagious variants are spreading fast
more than 2 000
cases of variants of concern have now
been confirmed across the country
in toronto almost 40 percent of all
reported covet cases
are now screening positive as variants
of concern
the vaccines are powerful but they are
not
beyond challenge we cannot take the
promise of vaccines
for granted federal health officials are
asking canadians to remain vigilant
until vaccine access fully expands four
different vaccines are now approved for
use here in canada
that doesn't mean though that you should
try to pick and choose which one you
want
what really matters is that they all
protect you from getting seriously ill
eric sorenson explains the vast majority
of canadians plan to get a covet 19
vaccine
yes i'd take anything as soon as i can
really yes but some vaccines
have shown higher efficacy than others
it's got olivia esther wondering
the thoughts crossed my mind i mean
which one am i going to get you know
always do i
have a choice and talbert johnson some
have this efficacy number that's higher
than others
you know that's a good point i
definitely thought about that i don't
know if we have a choice for which ones
we get
four vaccines have been approved in
canada the efficacy against mild covid
has found to be over 90 percent
for pfizer and moderna and between 60
and 70 percent
for johnson johnson and astrazeneca but
this is where the efficacy comparison
can be misunderstood somewhat
the trials have been conducted by
different companies in different ways
with different groups
and at different times johnson and
johnson for example held trials with
more older people
with underlying conditions jnj and
astrazeneca both held trials later
and in regions such as south africa
where covet variants emerged
when these trials were run there were a
different number of variants available
at the time
so you have this one vaccine trying to
do it all and
the fact that on average they're still
doing this well
is really good news many experts say
here are the most important numbers
for all vaccines protection from severe
covet is closer to a hundred percent
and protection from hospitalizations
also upwards of a hundred percent
though the data are changing and nothing
is foolproof the evidence overwhelmingly
suggests vaccines all but eliminate
hospitalizations and deaths
all of the vaccines will keep you out of
the hospital
all the vaccines will keep you out of
the morgue and those are the only two
things we really care about
so i encourage you to get your
vaccination when your turn comes
with confidence in the vaccine you're
receiving
some would prefer a specific vaccine
like johnson johnson
it works against the variance it seems
and it's a one shot
and and you're and you're done
propositions but tom chown says he'll
take what's offered but at this point
anything
most will including talbert the first
one that that's available
and olivia yeah i'm gonna get vaccinated
you bet growing recognition that
vaccines bring the ultimate goal within
sight
i'd like to get be vaccinated and carry
on with life
life a little closer to normal eric
sorensen global news toronto
a house of commons probe into sexual
misconduct allegations against the top
brass of the canadian military is now
expanding
the defense committee has agreed to call
several senior liberal officials to
testify including
another round with the defense minister
military police are investigating former
chief of the defense staff general
jonathan vance who has denied any
wrongdoing
and the man who took over from him
admiral art macdonald who has
temporarily stepped aside
the development follows an exclusive
report by global news detailing how the
canadian forces
found out about the allegations against
mcdonald's michael couture is following
this story for us
tonight a lot of women in the canadian
armed forces who have sworn an oath to
protect each and every one of us
and it is our duty as this committee to
protect them from sexual harassment in
the canadian armed forces
the vote to do that was unanimous across
party lines and there's a sense of
urgency
to expand the probe on sexual misconduct
in the military to include
allegations against former chief of
defense staff
art mcdonald sources tell global news
lieutenant commander raymond trotter has
been the subject of threats from
anonymous callers
after he came forward with a misconduct
allegation towards mcdonald
after sources say trotter was approached
by a female subordinate
those threats are why the committee is
attempting to compel trotter to testify
he's a person that's still in the chain
of command according to reports
and news last night by global he's
already faced intimidation and threats
that his career is over
so we want to make sure that he feels
free to appear without
fear of reprimand the threats have led
the conservatives to accuse the liberals
of abuse of power and
a cover-up when it comes to their
handling of the allegations
of sexual misconduct in the military and
it's why several senior officials will
be called to testify
including the defense minister's former
chief of staff
zita astrovez harjit sajin has been
asked to return to the committee
following last week's testimony where
former military ombudsman gary walburn
said he tried to tell seagen about an
allegation against
vance but that the minister refused to
see the evidence
why was the minister of defense more
interested in protecting his battle
buddy
than the men and women of the canadian
armed forces i disagree with this
testimony that mr baldwin provided to
the committee i look forward
to setting the record straight when my
opportunity comes to speak with the
committee thank you mr speaker
we asked the prime minister's office
about those alleged threats against
lieutenant commander raymond trotter in
response a spokesperson said quote
we condemn any threatening behavior
against complainants or anyone
bringing forward allegations it is
absolutely
unacceptable donna
all right mike look at you he's had to
make peace with it
coming up how the couple trashed the
palace and what happens next
canadians wanting a clearer picture of
the federal government's spending plans
will have to wait
the federal finance department confirmed
to global news there are no plans to
table a budget before the end of march
because parliament isn't sitting in
early april the earliest date possible
for a budget is mid-april
it's been nearly two years since the
last federal budget was tabled although
there was an economic update
in the fall there's also the prospect of
a federal election at some point this
year
no party wants one or so they say but
they all keep an eye on the opinion
polls
a new ipsos poll done exclusively for
global news shows the liberals have
expanded their lead
the ipsos poll shows if an election were
held today the liberals would receive
35 percent of the decided popular vote
up 2
from last month the conservatives led by
aaron o'toole
stand at 28 percent down 2 percent
the ndp are at 16 the green party at 10
and the block quebecois at 7 the only
poll that counts of course is on
election day but the upheaval of the
pandemic
does not appear to have hurt the
liberals politically and the challenge
for the conservative leader is
finding a way to gain traction our chief
political correspondent david aiken is
looking at this david
the challenge for o'toole is not just to
win over voters but also it seems some
skeptical conservative mps
yeah you know don in fact there are a
lot of conservative mps who
are deeply unhappy and frustrated with
o'toole's leadership
none mind you would come on tv to voice
their concerns
but i have talked to about a dozen mps
today and over the weekend
and it is a significant group mostly
from western canada
and from rural canada o'toole's first
misstep they tell me was the decision to
boot
social conservative ontario mp derek
sloan
out of caucus it was done wrong and done
for the wrong reasons
and that came as o'toole was doing
what's been described to me as
a pivot from the persona he took on to
win the leadership
race it's time for a true blue
conservative
who can win the next election to what
he's perceived to be now
a red tory from eastern canada in a
conservative circle's donna calling
someone a red tory
well that can be fighting words now
these mps now worry
o'toole's red tory tendencies will
result in a climate change policy
that puts a price on carbon in other
words a carbon tax
and that's a mainstream idea among all
other parties
but that is anathema to most
conservatives
finally many in his caucus are upset at
the removal of pierre poliev as finance
critic pauliev is very popular within
his party
and o'toole's decision to make pauliev
the jobs critic
well that is seen largely as a demotion
of a potential leadership rival
david what then could be the path
forward for the tories and for o'toole
himself how do they fix this
well the party's convention next week is
going to be
a crucial benchmark and uh sloan and
many social conservatives
uh will be out to sandbag o'toole uh and
he has to make sure that he prevents
that from happening now o'toole also his
supporters say
is a much more confident leader than his
predecessor andrew scheer
and he has to show it now o'toole must
also convince
western and rural mps and party members
that he can deliver votes in eastern and
urban canada
and he has to do that without alienating
that western and rural base
it's a tall order but o'toole must
address this frustration in his own
ranks
before he can address the concerns of
the canadians he'll need to win over
to win an election donna david aiken in
ottawa thanks
in minneapolis jury selection in the
case against the fired cop accused of
killing george floyd has been delayed
the judge paused proceedings until
tomorrow while an appeals court decides
whether to reinstate a third degree
murder charge in the case against
derrick chauvin chauvin has pleaded not
guilty to second-degree murder and
manslaughter
floyd an unarmed black man died after
being pinned under the knee of a white
officer for nine minutes
the incident sparked international
outrage about police brutality and a
movement for racial equality
today people gathered outside the
courthouse in minneapolis calling for
justice for floyd
three officers face aiding and abetting
charges
they will be tried separately
ahead the pandemic's toll on working
women why many are paying
a higher price
you're watching global national
there are more than 19 million women and
girls in canada they make up half
our population yet even in 2021 females
don't always have the same opportunities
as their male counterparts
especially working women that came into
sharper focus
during the pandemic and on this
international women's day abigail beeman
looks at how covid has set some women
back
rallying outside long-term care homes
care workers across
ontario call for better pay protection
and respect for working women
[Music]
emily coulter understands the struggle
well she's a personal support worker who
contracted coven 19 in the first wave
and when you can't be there for your
young children and
they're not understanding why it breaks
you you there's a lot of stigma
associated with stress burnout
abby sriharin studies the impact of
coping 19 on the healthcare workforce
she's seen women at all stages of their
careers leave their jobs
it's a woman's issue she can't handle it
so let's give her some tools to manage
but if we don't make systems level
changes
we are going to see this happen of
course it's not just healthcare
since february 2020 more than 80 000
women have left the workforce
compared to 25 000 men in ontario
women's employment rate has fallen back
down to levels it was last seen in 1993.
in alberta it's 1984. armenialnesian
says this is the first recession where
women
lost their jobs first and to build back
from a
she session we need more women
specifically in the caring economy
taking care of the old the young and
those too sick to work
it requires future thinking and planning
and we're not really good at that
we just kind of want to reopen the
economy and have everything work again
while for those parents still in the
workforce
and as cool as people can be when your
children bust through a zoom meeting
with a handful of legos
it is still a complete mental
distraction for the parent
nearly two-thirds of women reported they
were the parent most responsible for
homeschooling or helping kids with
homework
compared to 19 percent of men normally
before we would have
our grandparents or our you know our
parents to help us with the kids and
play dates with
with nanny and tito and that that that
is no longer available because we don't
want to put them at risk
carla briona says the pandemic has
exacerbated the need
for affordable child care abigail beeman
global news
ottawa